you don't buy a delorean unless you want
attention like you don't want to be out
in a delorean if you're having a bad day
because everybody's honking at you and
giving you thumbs up it's almost like a
happiness mobile
even with like 20 other deloreans parked
around like what is the story with this
one
the first time i saw delorean was in a
science museum i want to say in 1983
they had a brand new delorean the car of
the future parked in the lobby of the
science museum it became my dream car
and i always always wanted to own one
but it always seemed like wanting to own
you know magnum pi's ferrari or the van
from the a team like something
impossible that would never happen
i wrote this novel ready player one the
protagonist is kind of obsessed with 80s
pop culture and uh he loves doc brown's
time machine but he decides to take doc
brown's time machine and then mash in
three more of his favorite 80s super
vehicles the ghostbusters ectomobile
ecto-1 hit from knight rider and then
bukru bonsai's jet car
so it has both a flux capacitor for
traveling through time and an
oscillation overthruster for traveling
through solid matter
i never imagined that i would finish the
book or that i would be able to sell it
or that it would become a movie but all
those things happened and once i sold
the movie rights then i realized i could
i could actually buy a delorean finally
and then recreate the delorean from the
book it makes me a lot more interesting
at my book signings when i pull up in a
time machine and it's like a traveling
80s museum
this is my uh ipad that i use to control
my time circuits this operates the flex
capacitor but mostly it's just fun like
at the stop light i just pretend that
i'm dropping oil like spy hunter and
then i also have kits a little
consideration would be a beginning and
my light bar when i need to clear
traffic because i need to get to you
know the site of a job and bust a class
5 full roaming vapor i can't be sitting
in traffic
i love people who love the things they
love so passionately that it's just not
enough for them to
talk about it it has to manifest itself
in their lives somewhat they have to
build their own time machine or they
have to cosplay you know their favorite
character
i'm that kind of person and so the car
is a way for me to to do that
you